Fifty Shades freed co-star Rita Ora  returns to the stunning South of France  it's really nice to kind of celebrate  the end of an era I would say like  exactly we're filming the final  installment comes out on blu-ray Tuesday  and this actually charged story even  opened Rita's eyes I didn't know I had  any complaints but I don't get it  but yeah definitely like broadened my  imagination Sean Eric Johnson plays  Anastasia's villain his ex-boss that  full beard is for the History Channel  drama Vikings but Eric's not worried  about no longer looking sexy I had like  one scene where I'm like playing like  handsome boss that maybe he's nice and  then the rest of it is all like and he's  a pervert oh wait he's trying to murder  me  [Music]  [Applause]  you